[Musique]
trouver leur tarif dans la zone d'accouchement
qui est un nouveau ferry de Norfolk, la vie n'a pas d'
importance aujourd'hui là, je vais ramener un
peu à la maison sur le style led comme vous le faites
oh et maintenant vous continuez à faire tous vos
trucs de gangster je suis juste  essayer de vendre
ma maison ne vous inquiétez pas du fait que
tout le monde essaie juste de s'entendre et d'
avoir une bonne vie toutes les races sont
différentes simplement parce qu'elles sont différentes
ne signifie pas que quelqu'un est meilleur ou pire
que n'importe qui
hé ouais où est la diversité sur  Je
dois faire avec ma voiture je ne l'ai pas demandé
mais le monde entier regarde oh c'est
bon tu ne m'aimes pas je ne suis pas ici pour
être ton ami j'ai besoin de savoir merde
retour ne peux pas le cacher
ce qui dans la ville physique raconte comme le
visage
quel est mon visage avec toi et il a besoin de
beaucoup plus d'amour conjugal Hector ne me fais pas un
clin d'œil comme ça
toujours comme toi trois questions nous Adam
maintenant nous montre en route attends le
cotes de capital nous sommes la cavalerie qu'est-ce que
la magie saxonne
comme une arme nucléaire qui gr  les fourmis souhaitent
que ce que tu veuilles
soit plus grand ou plus court tu veux 10 millions de dollars
tu n'as pas l'impression que c'était
de l'eau pour sécuriser
[Musique]
quand une note je viens d'
Elte Saturday Academy non ils ne lui
donnent pas un concombre
pas très sûr
je ne peux pas sortir de ma main
[Musique]
c'est un début
nous pourrions être la promesse nous'  n'êtes pas dans une
prophétie, nous allons viser dans Toyota
Corolla
vous